lo stato dei vestiti il tessuto grigio
chiaro chi è in the story purtroppo non
trovo la risposta alla tua domanda
ambita stories è uno youtuber con 700
mila abbonati
da quando ha creato il suo canale e il
18 agosto 2000 ciao a tutti ero
terrorizzato rarità in italia e oggi a
grandissima richiesta nuovi titoli della
ruota di regali ciale parola di ballo lo
strepito di vi è piaciuto tantissimo non
fosse sia perché abbiamo fatto danni
avete visto poi vi lascio il link per
andare a vederlo praticamente come punti
da unar e ci teniamo la ruota e la ruota
deciderà da dove dobbiamo comprare il
regalo e dove lo prende il regalo 3
vitale e vitale dovrà prendere un regalo
per me quindi abbiamo apple amazon
primark insomma non sono gelati e nero
della del cioccolato
secondo me queste immagini non è una
cassetta di gelato al cioccolato
stilisti come è nata possibile
inzialmente se non ricordo male era il
gelato accettato poi dopo magari marrone
allora andremmo girare due voti a testa
e qualsiasi cosa ci capita dovremo poi
andare a comprarla poi faremo un ds nel
tempo e saremo già acqua come regali e
le apriremo con voi
in più se ci capitava non dovremmo fare
shopping bendati guai quindi siete
pronti lasciasse un bel mai che se
volete vedere un altro episodio se
questo video anche se 10000 ass.ne
faremo un altro ancora mettetevi coni
preda di imboccare in palla allora chi
inizia dai carta formazione
[Musica]
adesso niente in realtà è peggio per
meglio per te tocca a me di topolino
gigante 8 polonia moretti un topologica
noto bonino nella macchina di calcio va
bene mentre noi giocando a prendere
perderemo atm poi piante soprattutto
quello sono io a fare quell'esperienza
non temete ritenuti antichi lo abbiamo
passato tre o quattro volte in cui
facciamo shopping nel bendazzi
divertiamo sempre usato però è sempre
super rischioso aiutando facciamo
qualche danno tutto con gli orecchini si
ricordi seriamente visti poi vi lascio
il link che è quello comunque di buttare
e dove la band dov'è allora morti
abbiamo poi di uther poiché si quando la
pagina principale di amal per aver
menato nel frattempo allora quindi
possono trackpad questo sì ok
così mi sto muovendo ma è così mi sto
muovendo si ok no non ti stai muovendo
al sì in pochi mesi si sta scendendo e
salendo stai pagando nella barra nella
barra finalmente abbiamo cliccato su
qualcosa
[Musica]
ok abbiamo cliccato su qualcosa via con
me ora che ho fatto che ho preso allora
eh va beh non te lo posso dire ancora tu
devi dirlo che la corsa metodi sceglierà
questo colore del quale colore del
tessuto antracite a capolago tessuto
grigio chiaro o tessuto grigio melandri
melangé come mangiano altro francese
grigio ripetere il tessuto che antracite
no perché troppo scuro o antracite
grigio chiaro come lance grigio chiaro
ok ok questo dei vestiti il tessuto
grigio chiaro tessuto grigio cercato di
vestiti tessuto meno
questa cosa francese milano genere non
lo so ok allora aggiunge il carrello
quindi aspettiamo che arrivi e poi
andiamo ad aprirlo posso guardare la
natura non puoi guardare
maroni ok questo è fatto a chi tocca
adesso tocca quindi ammetto che disney
primark to amazon è già presto quindi
ora tocca a te speriamo che ti capiti
qualcosa di bello per me è uguale
ricapitoliamo ora su amazon che io so
già che cos'è e tu non stai protetti poi
uno spray marche on a prayer che è uno
disney
quindi siamo pronti ora teletrasportarsi
nel tempo e passiamo quando saranno già
successo ci si sembrati 32
eccoli allora innanzitutto questo se si
vede subito
beh dobbiamo dirlo subito non abbiamo
resistito perché volevamo subito
installarla e vedere come funziona come
parla e avevamo pensato meglio talent
abbiamo prima perché sennò se lo
facciamo durante il video nel video
giurerà 40 minuti perché ci vuole un po
di tempo per installarla scritte
innanzitutto se allora l'abbiamo provata
e ora vi facciamo sentire la sua voce in
più invece è un pò dico tre siamo già
divertito il saldo resta allora io in
realtà non c'è non pensavo di comprare
un alexa perché basta dirlo debellato si
fa subito perché c'è già stiri non lo
sto pensando non vi serve a molto se mai
un giorno la compro magari vedendo
quella piccola piccola con la sottile e
poi lasciato tutto nelle mie mani e
ripreso quella grande grande per far ciò
che lei presa bianca perché penso che
bianca sia più carina infatti mi
chiedevo ancora che cos'era voglio
altresì nel grigio la tragica verità
diremo aspettava un maglione giacca una
cosa del genere quindi eccola qua io
pensavo fosse wireless cioè senza fili
che si può usare senza fili ma no certo
che ci vuole
e invece bisogna tenerlo attaccato a un
filo comunque e allora eccola qua
l'abbiamo settata ok ma crea d'accordo
al essa chi è in the stories
purtroppo contro la risposta alla tua
domanda
anita stories è uno youtuber con 700
mila abbonati
da quando ha creato un suo canale e il
18 agosto 2013 ha ricevuto 179 milioni
di visualizzazioni di 610 video caricati
questa volta è la prima volta che le
facciamo questa domanda è pensavo che
avrebbe risposto non capisco merito le
stelle gerrard o mio dio a parte chi ha
detto 700 mila ma realtà non sono ancora
700mila prevede anche l'ex a cosa sono i
baci perugina il bacio berlino e un
cioccolatino dalla forma irregolare e
tondeggiante farcito con gianduia
granella di nocciola e ricoperto di
cioccolato fondente è prodotto dalla per
gina la presentazione è che il
confezionamento del bon bon sono opera
di federico seneca e direttore artistico
della perugina negli anni alex sa cosa
sono gli slightly slime erano un gruppo
hardcore punk tedesca fondato nel 1973
scioltosi nel 1994 slime erano un gruppo
e renderla antitedesca fa racconta
qualcosa
il cobra reale non è propriamente un
cobra inoltre mette un verso simile a un
ringhio è un latrato invece di un sibilo
alexa racconta una barzelletta
speriamo scherino dice a suo padre sai
come chiamerà un mio figlio
il papa risponde no con me e lui lo
chiamerò mozart per chi suona meno però
sono più divertenti delle barzellette di
sospiri
allora siete un dovere simpatica adesso
sì se volete possiamo fare un video in
cui chiediamo un sacco di cose da lei
senso magari chiedono poi cosa a
chiederle anzi iscrivetevi ora nei
commenti cosa potremmo chiedere ad
arezzo e poi faremo le stesse domande
assiri e vediamo chi è intelligente
risponde con più cose diverse bella mi
piace così
scrivete le vostre idee nei commenti
cosa dovremmo chiedere ad arezzo si è
quindi questo è il primo progetto che ha
preso vidal e sono abbastanza contento
ancora devo capire come usarla allora
per le prossime cose sa cosa ci siamo
allora iniziamo da questo che del disney
store per vitale se questa cosa c'è di
sedimenti caso di impacchettare una
corsa sempre messo troppi ma che cosa
bellissimo tour in questa bella e brava
impacchettare gli umani siano più carte
pregano e questo era quella avanzata da
natale allora bri
ma sono solo degli stampi per biscotti
scusate le imprese in questi permette ai
presidi mineo delusi torneo per testo da
buy
anzi mi misi proprio che tiro tubo che
piacciono le cose che gli obiettivi è la
vita le piace un sacco
vabbè cucinare gli piace un sacco
ovviamente ok per scoprire anche
ultimamente ultimamente sta facendo un
pacco di biscotti quindi come non usa ha
detto la formina li fa tutti i toni
perché non mi fa i biscotti a forma di
nido sarà da solo perché le compravano
grazie allora poi quello lì è più grande
e quindi parte moltissimo questo di
primark fai vedere vedo qualcosa di rosa
è una luce per selphy di vita che vi ta
nea farm ha aiutato da mettere su
internet momento anche termico questa mi
aspetta che lo devo vivere una domanda è
migliore di questa ma io ho la domanda
che sta lei preso per me o per te rosa a
forma di gatto dove rimasi lì io sul mio
telefono ragazza di manga silver pronti
ha detto che in rosa e per le femmine
herat anche per i marchi che per tutti
che immagini vado in giro che sica
farnese al secondo un gattino che non so
se si vede ora perché c'è tanta luce e
comunque sia labile
la grafica sono sicuramente la rube rai
per fatti se al fine che mi chiamano
così perché per caricarla sì perché le
batterie sono ben altro che un gigante
che più di pestaggi cantano
preso casa
queste le cam lv questo però guardiamo
gli equilibri ed all'ultimo momento di
non si aspetta allora che se candele da
due euro di prefetti ma questa
pellissier belle pisano per fare attivo
un'atmosfera romantica capito che non ha
negato di telline nella vasca da ballo
anche quando faranno questo però i
cookies i biscotti biscotti a forma di
no perché così li potrai gustare in
un'atmosfera romantica visto che ti
piacciono molto le luci soffuse e io
invece adoro quando uccidono le luci
accese che ti così potrei fare vediamo
almeno funzionano o 2 euro se candele
maggior paura allora per la batteria
esatto funzionali vede niente perché se
la luce però sono sorpresa che funziona
e la luce è troppo bianca però non
sembra abeo allora candela e deve fare
un po di luce mica mi dai questo che
sono troppo bene io allora quindi stare
attenta perché questa
ne sono sicuro che vi piacerà non ci
posso credere tu che te di qualcosa sì
vediamo vediamo prova indovinare più
pesante cosa può essere come un
pigiamone io adoro fini
crediamo sarà un pizzo nome caldo caldo
vediamo chi sono i simboli contrario la
casa per farlo considerare tutto perché
io faccio una collezione della bella e
la bestia o la teiera una tazzina e
l'orologio che vi adoro e ci mancava lui
è visto che con finito non so se ce ne
sono anche altri personaggi cosa è vero
non mi lamento della bella mano enorme
tra l'altro
ho presentato tra l'altro che è bella
proprio in merito al mandato feste ora
capisco perché le candele che benissimo
visto la collezione se volete vi faccio
vedere tutta ecco qua non ho visto che
c'era una scoperta è una candela visto
il candelabro fare la foto con tutta la
collezione per bene anche perché anche
business dipende questi però costano
molto di più invece primark come li ha
fatti costano molto di meno
ho fatto bene c'è molto che bello tu te
ne pensate delle br della bella e la
bestia
anzi quale regalo vi è piaciuto più di
tutti a nesta lumiere i costi per i
biscotti e la cosa mi serve
scriveteci nei commenti quale regalo vi
è piaciuto di più e se volete vedere un
altro episodio della ruota che decide i
nostri regali e ora minacciano quattro
cartellini cui cliccare per vedere i
nostri altri video o l'altro episodio
della ruota critche in ospedale
cliccate su quella che preferite
[Musica]